[Applause]
I'm sure you've had the discussion with
your friends at some point why are flats
getting so expensive it doesn't matter
if you live in Los Angeles San Francisco
or London we're talking about a really
global problem then again we should
first question is this actually a
problem at all or is it just you know
basic economics
[Music]
whatever it is we're talking about a
phenomenon that's happening in all the
big metropolis for example in the city
of Los Angeles the average rent has
risen 15% in the last three years and
let's be honest here if you have a
decent salary this is really more of an
inconvenience than it is a real problem
but let's imagine that you're a shop
assistants in a lie even better let's
imagine that Xander is a shop assistant
in LA what what happens here Xander if I
were a shop assistant in Los Angeles I
would probably be making around $2,000 a
month 540 square foot studio apartment
in South LA which is a very cheap
neighborhood can cost about $1,200 a
month
this would mean that 60% of my pre-tax
salary would go to rent the rest would
go to basic needs like food and clothing
so yes I would have a hard time saving
money with that salary now in an ideal
situation you would only spend about 1/3
of your salary on your rent or mortgage
so you'd have enough to live comfortably
and to save some money spending 60% of
your income on rent means that just a
small increase in prices could knock you
below the poverty line and yes that risk
is a lot more real than you might want
to believe
Los Angeles homeless population hits
36,000 in dramatic rise but this is not
the end of the story
I mean think about this here a visual
politic we always say that the world is
getting bigger
we're wealthier we're healthier and we
have better lifestyles this is partly
because stuff is actually getting
cheaper here's an example during the
nineteen seventies only 20% of Americans
had ever flown on a plane why well
because between Los Angeles and New York
the trip would cost you 1500 of today's
dollars now this very same flight it
only costs 200 thanks to this I'm sure
most of you watching have already
traveled more than your grandparents did
in their entire lifetimes the same goes
for other goods everything is becoming
more and more affordable except houses
no matter if you rent or if you buy you
have to make the same if not more
sacrifices than your grandparents
generation did in stock on there are
people living in a hundred and fifty
square feet flats in fact it's not
uncommon to meet couples in Sweden who
want to divorce but are waiting for
their spouse to find another flat but
the real question here is why our flat
rentals going so sky-high can we solve
this problem with better policies well
today we're going to answer these
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history reply demand
and the rest it is a universal and
logical facts the population grows in
every country just a decade ago America
at 300 million people now they have 27
million more but not all cities grow
equally if you're watching this video
from Detroit or Cleveland's you've
probably noticed that there are less and
less people around most of your friends
they're leaving the city and where are
they going
yep they're going to cities like LA on
New York so what does that mean it means
that the demands for living in those
cities keeps getting higher this is
totally ok and it is natural but here is
the real problem if we're talking about
a normal market supply it can rise to
satisfy that demand for an example let's
look at oil markets we've told you a
million times here a visual politic how
Saudi Arabia decreases or increases its
oil barrel production depending on the
markets needs it's easy they can
increase production from one month to
the other but when it comes to real
estate increasing supply means building
more houses and this takes time
besides the investment for a new block
of flats is huge and the profit margins
are around 3% and the truth is that we
need many many houses to cover to marked
California would need to build 3.5
million housing units by 2025 to close
its housing gap extract from a report
from McKinsey Global Institute October
2016 but why do developers have so many
problems building homes I mean we're
talking basic economics area it would
seem that if you entered the housing
building industry
you'd do pretty well in California well
of course you would but there's one
problem and that zoning laws you see the
real estate market is actually tightly
regulated by City Hall if you want to
build in LA you need a permit that can
take more than three years to get and
all of this happens because city
corporations are the ones who choose
where and how to build so how does City
Hall know how many dwellings they need
well mainly they look at population
growth if you check the data you'll see
that the housing centers in LA has
mirrored its demographic growth and
although it makes sense on the surface
this is a huge mistake because
population is one thing demand is
another
for example imagine a couple who lives
in one house if they get divorced all of
a sudden they need an extra house so
well there you go same population but we
just created twice as much demand and
the reality is that we have a higher and
higher single and divorce population
this is not happening just in Los
Angeles but also in Madrid in Berlin and
almost every other city many experts say
that the solution is to build more
houses mother's advocate for abolishing
zoning laws but in Europe many cities
that on price controls so do you think
these policies are working is it a good
or is it a bad idea well have a look
shall we the other Stockholm Syndrome
usually when we talk about Sweden is
because we're using them as a model
Swedish people enjoy a large welfare
state alongside a dynamic economy with
innovative companies among those is
Europe's most famous startup even though
it might not stand Sweden for that much
longer check this out Spotify threats to
leave Sweden's first startup protests
and Stockholm and as for you might be
thinking what come on Simon everyone
knows that Sweden is pretty open to
immigrants and well yes they are but
good luck moving to Stockholm and
finding a flat while we were making this
video actually spoke to a man who worked
for a Swedish startup for a year and a
half he made a salary of two thousand
nine hundred euros a month but more than
a half of that went towards paying rent
on a five hundred square foot flat and
believe me this was not the worst case
finding a flat in Stockholm is so hard
that some people spend months in an air
B&B as a now you might be wondering well
why
okay so it all started in the 1950s
Sweden needed houses so the Social
Democratic government created the
million houses policy the idea was to
build public houses for rent at very
cheap prices during those early years
every Swedish person could apply for a
public house and pay rent at prices
equivalent to four hundred or three
hundred euros today but things changed
in the 1990s
during those years Sweden suffered one
of the worst debt crises in their
history no money no more houses but the
rent regulations they still remained so
either you went for a public house or
you had to find a place in an extremely
scarce rental market basically in Sweden
they have the so called first hands
market those are the public houses
[Music]
if you're swedish the first thing you do
when you turn 18 is to apply there if
you're lucky in 13 or 16 years there's a
two-bedroom apartment waiting for you
for just 600 euros a month
in other words but you don't pay with
money you pay with time
this explains why 25% of the Swedes stay
with their parents until they turn 30
and it also explains why this society is
turning from renting to owning with
lower rates for mortgages most Swedes
buy as soon as they can but the real
question is what happens to people who
weren't born in Sweden what happens if
you just move there and have no family
to stay with well in that case welcome
to the wonderful world of these
secondhand market basically Sweden
believes that you shouldn't make money
from renting
the law has lots of ways to ban people
from renting and long-term rentals are
forbidden but even if you had a tenant
for a one-year contract the community of
your building can deny you permission
yep yeah that right your neighbors can
essentially say that you can't rent your
place out or you have to kick out your
tenants this explains why with so many
restrictions there are almost no
available flats so despite the great
welfare system many people live in 200
square feet flats but again the worst
problem is not the inconvenience it's
this we improved right in mainly
immigrant Stockholm suburb exactly the
poor immigrants have no capital to find
a flat and they have to go to the worst
neighborhoods then this is how ghettos
form and yes yes okay I know you've all
seen those conspiracy videos where they
exaggerate the gang violence in Sweden
but let's be honest even though the
problem is not as big as some media
portrays Sweden does have a clear
problem with criminality but we'll talk
about this in a future video in the
meantime if you're enjoying this video
so far do you remember we published
brand new videos every week so subscribe
to visual politic and hit that Bell
button so you receive a notification on
your phone anytime we post that would be
nice but let's get back to our story of
course this Stockholm crisis could be
solved by building more houses but even
if you built 80,000 new dwellings a year
as many have suggested could also badly
need to change those renting laws so now
you are you're thinking all right Simon
well now we've been waiting it's time
for you to tell us the magical solution
is there any example of a city that has
solved this renting problem and the
answer is yes let's check it out shall
we
[Music]
Vienna and rent for all system Austria
is one of Europe's wealthiest countries
the average salary here is over two
thousand seven hundred euros a month and
if you live in Vienna it's not hard to
find jobs that are paying more than 3500
euros a month nevertheless rent costs
are the same as a way poorer city like
Madrid Spain for 1500 euros you can find
an amazing 860 square foot flat in the
center of the city I know you're
thinking are come on out guys official
politicking gonna tell me another story
about how a city embraced the free
market with no remorse and lived happily
ever after right well no actually the
opposite is true
basically the Vienna Council is
something like a developer and a rental
agency at the same time they are the
city's biggest landlord you see after
world war 2 heart of vienna ended up
completely devastated by the bombing so
the city hall paid for all of the
reconstruction that's when they said
hold on a minute
since we pay for all this are we inside
it's also rented out under our own
conditions and this is how the world's
most ambitious public program started
here's how it works
80% of people in Vienna live in rental
flats 60% of those live in public
housing some of the buildings are from
cooperatives and others belong to City
Hall but hold on a minute
because we're not talking about normal
rental agreements yet in fact we could
call them something just short of
limited property basically rent
contracts in Vienna they last forever
even if you're dead yeah rental
contracts can be inherited so long as
you don't move you can stay and the flat
is yours ends well you should see these
houses in America in the UK we have this
notion that public housing is for the
poor and that is in bad neighborhoods
but here you can find public houses even
in the best neighborhoods and they're
pretty amazing the swimming pools gyms
even saunas
[Music]
[Applause]
in some cases it gets really absurd
while we're doing the research for this
video we spoke to Vienna City Hall and
they gave us a lot of cases for example
there's a young woman who lives in an
860 square foot apartment in the city
center and she thinks she pays for it
well yep only 400 euros a month that's
less than 500 dollars but a neighbor
living in a similar flat plays 2,000
euros why well he lives in one the
apartments that aren't public so just
like in Stockholm Vienna has two types
of renting control prices and free
prices and so now you might be wondering
well how come they don't have waiting
lists well here's your answer
[Music]
annually vienna spends about 600 million
euros or 682 million dollars on social
housing in comparison germany with a
population over 45 times Vienna
spends about 400 million euros
nationwide so you gotta be wondering now
well how does the system work let's say
you moved to Vienna in the first few
years you can't apply for public housing
but no problem there are more than two
hundred and ninety thousand flats on the
free market so it's not that hard to
find a place and the prices aren't crazy
because there's a large supply then
after only two or three years you can
apply for a public house depending on
your family status your income and your
pickiness it might be easier or harder
for you to find a home usually we're
talking about waiting times of no more
than two years of course as we always
say on visual politic not everything is
sunshine and rainbows
the first issue with this system is that
you don't want to move out of your flat
once you find it this model pretty much
reduces your freedom to choose basically
it's not you gets to choose that rather
City Hall and remember the your house
determines many things about your
lifestyle but there is another issue
here that sustainability
[Music]
this system relies heavily on just one
actor the Municipal Corporation this
means that as long as the local
government is the money there's no
problem but they just need one crisis
and there will be no more houses and
since there aren't many private
developers because there are no
incentives they could easily end up with
a housing shortage situation and this
would lead to a lot of problems but we
do have to admit that so far this model
does seem to be working so the question
now of course becomes would it be
possible to combine the Vienna model
with a more free market solution do you
think this system could be applied in
other cities as well would you mind
renting the same flat for your entire
life if the conditions were good enough
please leave your answer in the comment
section below
before finishing them me of a special
thanks to mark Soto and Jamie chap and
alpha helping us with the facts on
Stockholm also let me thank the Anna
City Hall for answering all of our
questions they were extremely nice don't
forget to visit our friends at ricans
and a Mediacom as well they're the
podcaster provided the vocals in this
episode and of course remember we
publish brand new videos every week so
subscribe to visual politic hit that
Bell button give us the thumbs up and
I'll see you next time if you want to
learn more about politics and world
affairs and here's some more of my
lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider @ww
re consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]